So the two specific types of sensory memory are iconic memory and echoic
memory. As I'm sure you're able to deduce from the names, iconic memory has to
do with visual stimuli, whereas echoic memory has to do with auditory stimuli.
Iconic memory is presented for only a very short amount of time. For example,
the picture we just saw. Echoic memory is a sensory memory for sounds. Echoic
memory is important for our ability to comprehend and understand language,
because we need to keep sounds in our memory long enough to be able to make
sense of them as words. So sensory memory is preserved for a very short period
of time. So if sensory memory is so brief in duration, how is it that we can
remember for example, someone's phone number or the directions to the gas
station?